[Music]
in cult-like news oh [ __ ] I love cults
submitted by Meghan she sounds like
someone would join a cult and get stuck
there i insult all the Meghan no I shot
to the making that's my second grade
girlfriend thank you can you remember
follow these steps to get your friends
and family out of a multi-level
marketing scheme
Oh my mom uses [ __ ] I [ __ ] love
pyramid scams they're so funny
every Asian mom has kind of been into
one low-key right yeah probably
they try to get me Luisana or Herbalife
amway at all those I've never been able
to get something to a pyramid scheme
ever hell no not mean I joined one you
know why because pyramid schemes still
required work thank you
lazy [ __ ] homie couldn't even get me to
the meeting you know so meeting like
dude it's so good it's a secret your
homies get like too crazy about that and
like it's so annoying they sell it to
you like this
wanna make full-time money on a
part-time basis yeah that's one of the
[ __ ] what are the ones is how would
like to retire your mom in like three
hours
oh that's a good thing it was a good
pair people that stand up these guys are
millionaires and they all stand I got
hit up on MySpace and then it was like I
could tell you're ambitious and you're
whatever I'm a how did you know all
these like beer is flattering me you got
that from Asian guy fly guy 96 know this
about me and that went to one of the
means and all the machinist corneas are
you it I went to one yeah it was for uh
this thing called Bartek you're supposed
to like convince all of her family to
change our phone lines over to you I was
in two by two that was one of the
biggest ones back in a day one of the
first a pyramid scam and I quitted it
all they sold Internet service you could
yeah I remember those if you have Lambos
with that decal on it
yo to buy there was one called like blue
light or something like that do you ever
doubt one okay but I remember like it
was like it was the friends was like oh
that date they wanted me to introduce to
like some older looking Asian dudes and
they all like pull up in like a Benz or
like it's an expensive car they're like
nice suits and [ __ ] the one that I did
was an energy drink company
they were doing some [ __ ] it was so
funny because the guy was talk to me
about it he goes oh like most people are
gonna buy stuff online I'm like a buy
[ __ ] online stupid manually predicting
the future yes straight up and all I do
is buy [ __ ] online it's not about that
right now forgive I bet you that guy's
like [ __ ] the little fat asian kid I was
right
that was like literally my dad like he
had a business and you know he was like
help me out take you know everyone's
like putting every all the products
online I'm like trust me dad's not gonna
stick then so last year more than
eighteen point six million people in the
US were employed by a multi-level
marketing it's true what they say
there's a sucker born every day every
day every minute right it's like even
work well I mean like someone turns 18
every year
those are the new customers you know I'm
saying there's so many scams now like
I'm like too skeptical now you know like
I'm always like second guessing
everything like I definitely stupid
phone call asking to like collect money
and [ __ ] I'm not a [ __ ] answering
this [ __ ] dude it was my dental office
they owe the money they were to call
collectors not be here for me it's
always the post mates people like when
they're like hey we're like just parking
am i cool oh [ __ ] you [ __ ]
and then it's not until they're like oh
let you post mates or whatever and I'm
like oh [ __ ] what I do
yeah I do my mind my you don't watch
your food sorry please come on how could
post mates drivers never have a local
number like mine's always a dumbass I
was like they're all from this area ya
know cuz if you try calling it after the
complete it doesn't work at all
I see possibly this has gotten a lot
better though because back in the day
they wouldn't even show up to your door
sometimes oh I never had that like when
they first started like some of these
drivers so far I hate that [ __ ] that's
the my worst peeve like if they don't
come straight to your door like I they
call me and they're like something like
they give me some kind of excuse I'm
like I'm watching a baby right now you
have
use the same one did you say what okay
yeah now I use that what I'm like no but
I'm babysitting I can't just move this
dude this dude literally told me he goes
oh post meets you were not supposed to
we were not supposed to go up like
stairs or some [ __ ] was like [ __ ]
exactly that was like so you're telling
me you cannot come upstairs like
literally it says that within your
contract it goes yeah I can't I'm like
alright cool cause I don't the flu
anymore you have to pay for it I still
paper but I still gave him a one-star
[Music]
about the two-hour drive to show the cop
like why would you pay for I don't want
that [ __ ] dude
oh so upset that means you're that
hungry that day you bought him lunch and
I put in a [ __ ] big ass complaint
alright no but see those post makes
people though like that dude was being a
[ __ ] [ __ ] like he just wouldn't do
it
and I'm like what the [ __ ] man like
what's the whole point if I have to get
out and Christ I think the same way
because if I'm we're willing to go out
downstairs lobby what could I live in a
building you know if I'm willing to do
that I'm willing to just go to the
restaurant yeah my my own thing like
there's a reason why I'm paying an extra
eight bucks for this is because you're
supposed to give it to me that defeats
the purpose right but you could have
just said that hey man kind of lazy and
I'm like she was honest to me but he was
adamant about lying to me I'm like [ __ ]
so wait how many how many people are
scammed more than eighteen point six
million people in the u.s. that's wild
yeah so they're also saying so the FTC
said that's a lot of money they found
that more than ninety nine percent or
idiot people who join em alone
ultimately lose money obviously yeah I'm
nice I'm probably like the only person
that made money on a pyramid scam did
you yeah
Jesus I mean I was told straight up cuz
I would never join any of those things
but he was like y'all teach you how to
make actually make money and then I was
like okay and then so I made money at
the expense you didn't make money yeah
cuz I recruited all my friends yeah
Ripoff somebody thinks so here's some
suggestions of what to do if you know
someone that's in one and you know like
they don't know how to get out or
whatever first of all don't buy anything
from them and don't join their team
because even though you're you want to
be supportive like you you feel bad that
they're you know that they're gonna be
losing money up just by joining the
thing by you buying from them you're
giving them false hope that advice you
get somebody how don't join the thing I
think that's going out to people that
are very like sympathy right right right
that's like the way of that's their
style yeah worst person that ever come
to them yeah so then they're also saying
to stay positive because in these MLMs
they brainwash people into thinking like
everyone's gonna tell you not to do this
because they don't believe in the
mission like they don't understand how
you can really make money like they
brainwash these people yeah they think
you're a hater people that are negative
and so the thing you have to do here is
stay positive you know like don't yell
at them for being in this pyramid scheme
cuz it's just gonna make them want to
prove you wrong even more and like
they're gonna be sucked in even more
tight yeah so they're saying to just
stay positive the other thing is to show
them the money which is like sit down
with them yes that mean that would be my
first step yeah until like have tell
them to like keep a detailed spreadsheet
of all the expenses and sales and then
calculate taxes in there because a lot
of these people they don't realize if
they are making some money that they
have to pay taxes on that and so once
they start saying how they're gonna
obviously be in the red then that might
snap them out of getting that time to
put a waste talking about money like
that people well I mean it's your friend
you forgetting a guy everyone in their
circle is not gonna know how to do that
either like 90 [ __ ] percent of people
don't know [ __ ] about finances don't
talk about money don't know Jax I think
subtraction and like positive and
negative I think is pretty simple you
know nemi it's simple but it's not
common like how many members within your
guys's family actually know how to do
finances like even basic not a lot lazy
no I'm pretty sure so I'm saying most
people don't know
[ __ ] that's why they joined these things
because I joined cuz I thought this was
real business I thought this is what
business was about sales and all that
[ __ ] and they kind of get you like that
especially they're probably recruiting
like eighteen year olds uneducated
people people that don't know [ __ ] about
like how the business world works and
endo like oh here's an opportunity you
know who don't like we're down in the
dumps who need an opportunity I was
recruited for one of them or like one of
my friends or whatever took me to one of
these meetings and then as soon as so it
was it didn't take long to figure out
like all this phony [ __ ] but then as
soon as they're like you know you got to
buy this thing I was like [ __ ] you like
I'm already a broke-ass student yourself
you're investing your you have to but
not dollars now not as millions there
for me I'm like I don't even have that
like you're trying to help me get money
how am I gonna spend money to make me
that didn't make sense my mom is the
stupidest one because she joy no she
joins this [ __ ] so she could buy her own
products not even reselling it like she
jointly herbal eyes she could just buy
from her friend know a lot of housewives
I think do that they do the same thing
that could lay by is it like this it is
a good product just so she could buy her
own [ __ ] cuz I've been selling it yeah
I'm pretty sure if any of our homies was
an impairment we'd clown the [ __ ] yeah
we would have try to get them out I
would just keep telling them to be in it
cost of the hair just watching us
they're poor he's like dude keep going
I had a several long hour conversation
with a close friend of mine and I was
like okay whatever you're gonna figure
it out eventually and I gave up and I
was like wow once they get in they just
have to learn for themselves did they
learn yeah how long like a couple years
later no like several months Jesus dude
that's still a long time of dedication
to anything dude
a couple months yeah anything we're just
like when you were like in high school
or something no this is like three four
years ago oh [ __ ] yeah with an adult
yeah okay but I mean this person doesn't
understand business like they wait they
do now like it's all the same thing like
a lot of people they get hopeful you
know and then these things are fun
like if you've ever been to one like a
legit one that does it right they turn
it into a party cry
and it's like you can hide she was a
threat it's fun to be there and you're
like oh [ __ ] like this is something
different I'm gonna join and I'm gonna
start selling product make money I can
work with my friends I don't want to be
in this toxic like job that I'm at right
now
it's like nothing is as good as it seems
it's like that will be boiler room right
there just doing fat rails strippers but
then you have to dig and rip off
somebody for all their [ __ ] yeah but
they don't see it as ripping off they
see it as helping others because they
get you brainwashed to do all kinds of
stupid [ __ ]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]